[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour merci d'abord avant qu'on voit
l'indiquent de l'aria qu'on voit ce
qu'il a moi j'ai une petite surprise
pour la digue de la rédac
sacha albas christian jacob c'est quoi
le problème bien vous savez j'ai votre
première télé ça chiale base sa première
télé l'a pas prise dans tout ce parcours
bosses nom soit il l'a fait bien avant
sa première télé sachez-le base
et oui c'était dans attention à la
marche or vous le regardez j'ai retrouvé
les regarde et bien sache albâtre
regarder ce h à la cantine jeu tous deux
chez gites ou non mais genre qu'est ce
que tu aimes pas la cantine par exemple
déjà ce que j'aime pas la cantine à la
maison les épées nord les épinards mais
quand avec moi dans public n'a pas agi
là là là il a 42 ans
[Rires]
franchement ça celle basée là oui et
quand sasha une base est là
malheureusement tant les chroniqueurs
tremble et oui le public bien sûr
prendre un malin plaisir à se moquer il
voit là et sont arrivés là j'ai fait un
bout j'étais sur france 3 vous adore oui
c'est cocasse ce cyril à la prochaine
séquence qui arrive c'est tout ce qui se
passe pendant les magnetto wheels avec
moi j'étais tout le week-end avec qui
jean luc reichmann
je vous embrasse je vous jure que ça va
vite et tout le week end avec jean-luc
que londres a d'ailleurs et vous
embrasse et il adore quand vous le
limiter à des combats une petite
imitation de alors voilà je fais
l'anecdote
alors bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
les 12 coups de midi
attention attention tout de suite je
suis avec guillaume bonjour guillaumat
bonjour bonjour à l'os qui parle vous
venez vous acheter une voiture mais a eu
un petit problème
alors c'est vrai parce que je t'ai donc
josé pour m'acheter une voiture donc
j'essaie d'y aller avant le couvre feu
donc pour aller chez le concessionnaire
hélas ma femme me dit choisi la voiture
et on l'aura dans un mois peut-être
qu'on sera plus en confinement c'est
génial son anecdote sais pas c'est pas
fini c'est pas fini donc là je vais à
17h30 aux dons peuvent choisir la
voiture il est le monsieur me dit je
peux vous la sortir à 18 heures voilà
voiture mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ensuite
bah en fait on va on a reçu la voiture
deux mois plus tard c'est dingue et
passe au rouge
il va gagner alors jean luc reichmann va
revenir dans un instant parce que il ya
attention à la loge tout ce qui se passe
pendant les jeux mais d'abord même si
j'ai tout ce qui se passe pendant les
magnétos art dans les pubs et ce qui se
passe ici sur ce plateau toutes les
petites saucisses du monsieur à côté de
moi sottise toutes les sottises ya il a
glané sur france 3 sur france 3 je reste
sur france 3 et tout ça c'est compilées
dans sa carte green inside
j'adore de pépé mel où c'est bien nikos
moulon salut à tous et bienvenue dans 50
sur hbo l'inside de pmp
mais on commence tout de suite avec
cyril hanouna qui a des envies très
particulière cette semaine j'ai envie de
danser la [ __ ] ça me manque trop quoi
y'a pas à dire nicolas pernikoff c'est
très bien je suis né les petites
nouvelles s'est pas entraîné
jaune sur le côté cette semaine exclu
qu'on ait eu droit au bail gentilhomme
tmp et pourquoi j'ai plus rien j'ai plus
aucun des congés plus rien qu'est ce qui
se passe
que signifie cette mascarade et au tour
réussi cette semaine pour jean michel
maire qui est toujours un très grand
arbre
je pense que tenir
j'aime bien ta du génie outre bernard
montiel dans la rien à cirer des
affaires de donner le mot amer a soif je
lui verse un peu elle a tout va cracher
et j'ai senti sa santé alors j'espère
qu'enfin j'ai espéré que c'était que
dans lequel ce n'était pas un produit
et puis pendant bas apprend l'arabe à
nicolas pernikoff ça donne ça soirées
sont ouvertes et on continue avec kelly
b novelli qui a toujours des expressions
qui tombe à pic et pic et colégram de
sorte à ce que même si ça arrive je
grave arrive il fait de mes chemin est
fait de mes chemin exactement après que
celle du césium genton qui se prend des
vents de force 5 dans thank you enfin ça
y est l'été approche
on se quitte avec le tout nouveau tube
de baba au fait qu à tous les jours au
fait caca dans la vie on fait caca tous
les jours en fait
qu'a donc à jour ont fait caca et jouer
c'est mon poto booba qui m'a fait
découvrir sa toison d'or sera avec nous
la semaine prochaine ne touche pas le
norway sera notre invité booba qui
viendra nous voir semaine prochaine chez
plus hissé jeudi je crois que c'est
jeudi prochain
denis prochain je crois de booba sera
avec nous et j'ai fait un énorme bisou
au poteau c'est lui qui m'a fait
découvrir dans la vie on fait caca tous
les jours on fait caca moment préféré ça
la fin c'est pas dit qu'on fait caca
dans la piscine et kaka sur le
trampoline vraiment à voiture le duce
coût de sa fougue dans la voiture je ne
rigole pas qui c'est qui chante cette
jolie chantant l'asie ont fait caca
c'est collectif
qu'est ce que tu veux une fille balles
massues tu vas dire sur rfm allez allez
on va écouter michel sardou les lacs du
connemara eddy mitchell couleur menthe à
l'eau et dans un instant fracas
ayrault dans le clip ya des croates et
tout mais bon message à un ami
et quand on est blond ont fait caca
courront quand on est brun ont fait caca
tout fin quand on y roule on fait caca
poumon foie la cg les chanteurs elle a
tous les talents
je les ai toutes les paroles aux côtés
de cyril avec un invité qu'on adore dans
tp qu'on a même reçu hier c'est l'avocat
fabrice division as well as quand il est
là il vient je suis tiré l'incroyable
défoncer tout le monde ah ouais mais
j'ai l'impression que cyril il prend un
malin plaisir c'est ma vie à ce que
fabrice di vizio des fonds sous le monde
je pense même qu'il invite que pour ça m
c'est ma vie après cyril l'animateur à
découvrez cyril langue renner
[Musique]
fabricio série va défoncer laisse le tue
mer et autres liqueurs sûreté défense le
défenseur venir évoquer des choses sur
lesquelles même les scientifiques les
plus imminents ça réfléchit pas raison
défonce le talon vous avez des gosses
qui incombe à ce que je sais moi tant
que juriste c'est qu'il ya une réalité
quand le gouvernement vous en prête une
liberté il oublie toujours de vous la
rendre prenez un petit peu d'eau c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau résolution c'est
que quoi vous dit quelque chose vous
puissiez note sabine et au tu toi papa
vraie division et mittal est jeune et
maîtrisez pas ouais c'est bien ce que
veut dire excusez moi monsieur sans
avoir d'abord lui non mais moi j'ai une
chance m'a dit tu vas te des fonds il va
te défoncer du show connaît il parlait
tous les deux leur destinée les entrées
en réanimation ni la nouvelle avait déjà
fait ce coup là monsieur s'il devrait
chauffer sa hotte amène du frais si l'on
lui va te défoncer je le connais on va
te défoncer sur le connaît du tout à
l'heure à avancer des chiffres alors je
vous demande un lien de causalité et
aime pas vous n'êtes plus malin que tout
le monde est défoncée quel bon sens dans
cette crise parce qu'il y avait une
petite mon disparu ma maison est un
exemple parfait à votre propos tu as des
fonds
et a défoncé et a défoncé je prends le
presto négocions c'est quand tu es
traduire ses études en dix ans
effectivement ça eu l'incidence est donc
principe de précaution on continue jusqu
à l'humidité collective non non non non
ouais mais c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche
justement si effectivement vous gagnez
l'excès par 60 40 et gouye que ces
niches mais vous après maxime rey et
omega pharma brise à mal ce matin
bon c'est vrai il a raison vote à raison
a dit avant toi c'est pas moi c'est ça
le problème
votre vision exceptionnelle
j'aimerais qu'on revoit en bonus hier un
des mes moments je pense à des plus
grand moment pour moi tpb de l'histoire
à la danse élever ses clips qu'il a dit
c'est qui lui est ce qu on la ola au
long de ses canaux la merci au caire
posé sur le fond vous chercher les
petits bugs mais après midi dans un si
beau
[Rires]
si je vous en prie c'est qu'ils
voulaient remonter mon projet c'est
incroyable mais le temps de fabrice vial
[Rires]
et si je vous en prie c'est qui
ça fait des années qu a pas une personne
c'est pas l'heure quelle mondiale bon ça
c'est exceptionnel et fabrice di vizio
il y aura un volume 2 parce qu'avec ce
qui s'est passé hier je peux vous dire
c'est pas engrais n'est hélas été
champion de boxe on continue avec une
rubrique que les téléspectateurs vont
beaucoup réclament mais cyril sur un
star et sur twitter
on parlait de jean luc reichmann tout à
l'heure c'est lui qui m'a amené toutes
les images et c'est tout ce qui se passe
dans les loges fait très attention à la
marche des coûts attention à la lok
oui salut c'est jean luc bienvenu dans
attention à la loge
mme subow possible nicolas pernikoff a
abusé et sur la tchèque tout cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais nous bernard montiel c'est vraiment
la caillera des loges du jeune public
très avantageux et emmerder mais y'a un
gros paquet non mr paris attention
attention qui dit vélo élite
il faut vraiment pas la chercher
décidément elle tire à balles réelles
niculae
après bernard montiel
je vous demande d'accueillir bernard
montiel
je sais que ça devrait bien enfin bon
petit monde de la télé c'est
complètement dingue casta et sa caste à
[Rires]
l'arrêt plus tout seul à la salle jean
avait un peu de vent et environs de
faire les enfants
c'est incroyable père des coffres pose
plus de questions que moi même pourquoi
le regardez moi ça jean michel maire du
tampon pocket
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de la question clos j'ai
surpris avec vers la matière depuis
quand t'as pas vu les longues et ce
n'est que leurre que tu sais faire plein
de choses rigolotes et un grand machin
comme ça très bon c'est ma fille est
garé la voiture
cyril est aussi calme en direct que dans
sa loge et en quoi elle est énervée
contre vous des films je sais pas en
fait la tête depuis cinq jours non et
l'huile ou du site me fais la dispute a
depuis cinq je n'ai pas très bien mais
ça lui fait macérer là les gentils en
plus value réelle est super sympa mais
pourquoi c'est la meilleure salle est
bon la vierge à vue hier salut mieux
bomba très bien ça s'arrange pour que
savez-vous guillon moi j'adore même film
sinon vous savez plus de polluer la tête
whisky et choix qu'il est un peu lourd
et kane a raison ça dénonce non eh bien
non mais croit je suis un peu
indifférent j'ai l'impression qu'elle le
nie pas très bien j'adore mais en plus
delphine sert l'amour est justement un
des fils m'a dit qu'il avait passé une
semaine je vous le dit nicolas
elle m'a dit qu'elle avait passé une
semaine fabuleuse qu'elle a fait toute
la semaine avec nous lundi jeudi elle
m'a dit qu'elle s'était régalée vrai ou
pas guillaume donc voyez à mon avis il
ya peut-être une petite brèche
voilà à lady n'hésitez comptant à saluer
vous allez franchement vous avez moitié
moins l'âge de son mec alors oui pour
finir on s'est intéressé au retour de
jean michel mr café faut le dire un
retour fracassant à cette semaine dans
touche pas à mon poste alors jean-michel
d'attenté pmp jean-michel il faut le
dire c'est un charmeur mais ouais il est
pas très bien en ce moment
bonjour expliquer pourquoi ça concerne
nicolas pernikoff puisque il s'est fait
voler la place la vedette par un os très
faible qui est à côté de lui mais sa
salle chafouine alors qu'en parce qu'il
a la cote nicolas bien oui il a la cote
et puis j'ai envie il se dit je suis
peut-être devenu un peu has been qua non
sinon alors que pas du tout alors normal
non
je vous aime regarder manier tout début
en soirée il ya deux ans non jean michel
maire est encore bien là mais alors qui
sera le btp mp a répond son image
ouais
tout a commencé avec le retour de jean
michel maire dans l'équipe de tpf en
l'absence de chauffer si le contrat
n'est pas là
le chien dans ce chien chien et chat tu
peur quand kelly vdo bélier révèle les
noms des cibles de nicolas pernikoff il
avait un nouveau sur nous dans l'équipe
[Musique]
a dit ça c'est rien coeur heureusement
nicolas pernikoff pouvait compter sur le
soutien de guillaume jan tout l'objet
des champs mitard barhoum une fois de
plus le bourg tôt dans la plaie
[Musique]
le respect par tous
c'en était trop pour jean mi nicolas lui
avait pris ses chroniqueuses sa place
son baba il décide d'en découdre véro
souvent avec lui je vais pas sur
instagram j'avais publié alors vous êtes
tous les deux beaux gosses starwing oui
et le non je le dis pour les
téléspectateurs
nicolas il parle à tout le monde c'est
un truc de fou même mois à la pub
dès que je fais par là bas je sais qu'il
va me parler pendant 10 minutes s'il a
dû même si la pub dure 7 minutes pas
parlé pendant 10 minutes
donc en fait c'est la voie la baie
valérie c'est un gentleman
oui bah oui moi je n'ai jamais vu avoir
une parole déplacée non non non will i
am il a bien parlé avec parle à tout le
monde
vous l'aimez bien nicolas ou pas
professeurs n'ont pas trop mais c'est
vrai que c'est tout pour cette semaine
non c'est parce que je garde quand même
qu'on revoit en longueur de mettre aux
divisions et les moyens c'est l'un des
bannis au coeur du bois vous reposer sur
des fonds vous cherchez l'effectif
[Rires]
quand et si je vous en prie c'est qui
lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]